comme autrefois nous l'avons été la
jeunesse est pressé
elle a ses problèmes et ses soucis
nous les avions aussi l'existence est
une affaire de fascinant
au chantage à ses plaisirs où il faut
savoir vié
avec eux
sourire la vie commence à 60 ans quand
on la connaît mieux qu'avant
et que l'ona
parrot
la meilleure façon de garder la forme
lorsque l'on à 60 ans et peut être un
peu plus c'est encore d'aller promener
son chien tous les jours au bois de
boulogne
et ce n'est pas innocent si qui nous
démentira en effet nous avons surpris le
chanteur en compagnie de nadal une jeune
chienne berger allemand propriété du
fils de tino leur hausse
les filles sont compliquées selon
toujours
je vais la rue dans la d62 admiratrices
du chanteur ses lecteurs se rassurent
elles n'ont pas être jalouse mais pour
le moment
regardons plutôt comment se déroule
cette promenade hivernale nous sommes
bien loin des rivages enseigner la corse
ce match
quand on attend
ces deux jours
m
bin hammam
voilà
question
allez hop
le secret d'une grande carrière c'était
aussi à un compositeur vous avez été
l'interprète de vincent scotto
c'est dire que vincent scotto à trouver
en moi un bon outil parce qu'il avait
déjà fait des milliers de succès il
avait d'élèves et les succès pour
maurice chevalier pour pour joséphine
baker pour georges elle pourtant
beaucoup de gens autonomes midi un homme
du midi oui mais après je crois que et
les trouver en moi des partenaires
idéals alors dit bon passons sur le
petit chêne
je crois qu'on doit aux téléspectateurs
la vérité c'est surtout la chienne de
l'an mais elle prend passion chez jeu
tino c'est ça l'un n'allant pas ce que
laurent déménager alors qu'on l'a laissé
quelques jours mais c'est là quand je
pars en voyage je laisse c'est ça pas
fou sa mère occupée par contre moi j'ai
deux chiens en corse ajaccio oui j'ai un
un bar rouge des normes chez noir et
puis comme auteur un boxer oui c'est à
dire une chaîne boxer il voulu beaucoup
de chiens j'ai toujours eu des chiens
toujours même quand j'ai tourné et j'ai
tourné des films j'avais
souvent des chiens j'ai eu même j'ai eu
même un phoque dans lumière de paris ah
oui oui oui mais sauvé par tous n'est
pas lui donner temps en temps quelques
poissons quand même linda gray un ami
des animaux
il doit alors justement ces chiens en
corse c'est des chiens de garde ou se
sont vraiment vos amis ce sont mes amis
et sans nos gardes armés ils ont
beaucoup de terrain alors ils peuvent
courir parce que ici à paris les chiens
ne sont pas tellement il faut dire ce
qui est bien que vous ayez quand même un
avortement qui sont idéales pour les
chiens parce qu'ils n'arrivent pas ce
qu'est le bois en face heureusement si
vous même qui fait de promenade avec le
chien tous les jours oui oui donc vous y
attend que vous voir je pense mais des
heures des heures de rock par wade a
parlé un petit peu de cette petite
chienne alors comment s'appelle-t-elle
nahd
pourquoi rade parce que c'était une
année en n1 simplement il s'appelait n'a
dit
on a enlevé le hip hop mais elle paraît
extrêmement jeudi en fines et intuitive
ainslie chiennerie éléments elle est
très douce et très affectueuse
à bois
pour la cia
et
si l'on voit de plus en plus souvent le
père et le fils réaliser des duos à la
scène il en est de même la journée pour
les promeneurs exceptionnellement le
directeur du jardin d'acclimatation du
parc de boulogne avait accordé à
l'équipe de 30 millions d'amis
l'autorisation de faire pénétrer
mademoiselle la ddt dans l'enceinte du
jardin
mieux jusque là interdit aux
représentants de la race canine
qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent apporter xiam
sur incident dans votre vie d'homme de
spectacle via ces espèces de
tranquillité mois que le chien c'est pas
le chien beauregard de vivre cette
extraordinaire
si vous êtes triste illettrisme aux
algues et les gays c'est c'est très
curieux lui ne parle pas malheureusement
mais c'est faux et leurs yeux parlent il
dans votre dans votre vie vous avez
d'autres animaux quand j'étais plus
jeune par exemple oui j'ai eu et j'ai
déjà des perroquets j'ai même un singe
toto et auto et s'appelait rivm adorait
se sert de cette échappée qui était
montée sous le toit du collège cela vais
prêter à quelqu'un et elle est venue me
chercher en lisant le singe veut pas
descendre les sur toit du collège
alors j'ai été là-bas je l'appelle au
total descendus et ont participé qu'à
l'époque où le mien je n'ai pas mal
avait entre 10 et 15 ans qui lors aussi
est ce que vous regardez l'émission 30
millions d'amis qu'est ce qui vous
intéresse dans cette émission
ça m'intéresse de fait que en défend les
animaux en étant les animaux et on les
monte peut-être nous allons un peu
nouveau peut-être remonte les relations
que ça ne regarde que c'est à dire
qu'avant on ne savait pas ce qui se
passe les animaux les animaux qui
souffrent les animaux qui sont
malheureux les animaux qu'on tue et je
trouve que cette et mes chiens très
bonne pour ça et c'est ennuyeux pour un
un homme de spectacle et gala les
enregistrements de d'avoir une chaîne
comme ça dans sa vie si je puis dire
mais pas du tout parce qu'elle sied
habitué une façon ordinaire qu'elle
reste toujours tranquille et comme elle
vient elle vient en studio et dur en
studio elle vient en studio elle adore
ça même ma pièce devrait la faire la
france jusqu'à la version et quels sont
les projets que vous avez en semblant et
hino et je prépare un nouvel album pour
la rentrée avec des dessins de chansons
de chansons d'amour pour changer mais
les duos tino laurent c'est une chance
de continuer c'est à dire oui pourquoi
pas c'est de dire que le jour
on a une bonne idée on nous présente
quelque chose qui nous plaît qui avec
une idée nouvelle en fin du show
original on le fait le décompte vers 1h
dans un duo alors qu'un trio trio
pas derrière
qui a compté pour toi
non
oubliée
jme
m
à
faux